trabajando juntos aransay jorge pintó en
una barda en ocho horas está muy larga
la barda en el año pasado
aranza pintó la barda ella solita hace
dos años jorge pintó la barda solito
pero se tardó el doble de lo que se
tardaba lanza cuánto tiempo se tardaron
naranja y jorge cuando estaban pintando
la verdad son los que hay entonces lo
primero que vamos a hacer es definir
algunas variables digamos qué
va a ser igual el número de horas el
número de horas que se tarda aranza
s
tarde arantxa
danza en pintar la verdad
y tal
[Música]
verdad que entonces
ansa
entonces arantxa se tarda a horas
horas en pintar una barda se tarda a
horas
cada vez que pinta la barda tiene una
velocidad de a horas por verdad bueno
pero esto lo podemos invertir es decir
esto es exactamente igual a decir que
aranza pinta uno entre a partes de la
barda
por ahora cada hora a danza pinta uno
entre partes de la verdad de estas dos
cosas son exactamente igual es decir que
a danza se tarda a horas por barda a
decir que a danzar pinta uno entre a
partes de la barda en una hora
entonces se lanza tiene una velocidad de
1 entre a bardas por hora y bueno ya que
definimos que esta variable a para
lanzar pues vamos a hacer lo mismo con
jorge no vamos a decir que jota es igual
a el número de horas que se tarda jorge
en pintar la verdad
tarde
corrige
en pintar en pintar
[Música]
verdad aunque entonces
jorge se tarda jota horas cada vez que
pinta
la verdad y esto otra vez es exactamente
igual a decir que jorge pinta una jota
encima parte de la barda cada
ahora bueno entonces ya que tenemos
nuestras variables bien definidas ahora
sí vamos a hacer cálculos aquí lo que
nos dicen es que a aranza y jorge
pintaron una barda en ocho horas que
entonces
[Música]
y jorge
jorge nosotros sabemos que juntos se
tardaron ocho horas ocho horas
en pintar una vez la
verdad ahora esto es exactamente lo
mismo así que cada vez que pintan la
barda
se tardan 8 horas que se tardan 8 horas
y bueno esto también es exactamente lo
mismo a decir que pintan una octava
parte de la barda cada hora y que
entonces la velocidad con la que arantxa
y jorge pintan la barda cuando están
trabajando juntos nos la dieron en esta
oración y es un octavo de barda por
horas ahora la velocidad con la que
trabajan juntos pues tiene que ser igual
a la velocidad con la que harán zapping
está la barda nadas la velocidad con la
que jorge pinta la barda no entonces un
octavo de verdad por horas que es la
velocidad con la que pinta la barda a
lanza y jorge cuando trabajan juntos
tiene que ser igual a 1 / a 1 / a
qué es la velocidad con la que pintar
ansa
no voy a poner las unidades pero
recuerden que unidades tienen que ir que
son bardas por ahora nada la velocidad
con la que pinta jorge que es 1 / j
entonces lo que tenemos es que un octavo
de barda por horas es igual a 1 entre a
bardas por horas nadas 1 / j bardas por
horas ahora aquí lo que tenemos son dos
variables desconocidas
y j y una sola ecuación entonces si
realmente queremos averiguar cuánto vale
a y cuánto vale j necesitamos otra
ecuación así es que no nos queda de otra
que regresarnos al enunciado del
ejercicio y buscar algo más acerca de
estas variables
entonces trabajando juntos serán seis
porque pintaron una barda en ocho horas
eso ya lo tenemos contemplado el año
pasado a lanza pintó la verdad ella
solita hace dos años jorge pintó la
barda él solito pero se tardó el doble
de lo que se tardó aranza eso nos da más
información así es que ahora vamos a
usar esta información jorge se tardó el
doble de lo que se tardó harán
y eso lo que significa es que la
cantidad de tiempo que se tardó jorge
que es esta jota esta jota la definimos
aquí es igual a dos veces porque es el
doble de lo que se tardó aranza pero lo
que se tardó balanza es una a porque
aquí definimos esta variable entonces
esta oración nos dice que jota es igual
a 2 por a
y entonces cota es igual a 2
[Música]
y podemos usar esa información por aquí
entonces lo que tenemos es que 1 entre 8
es igual a 1 entre la cantidad de tiempo
que se tarda a aranza más 1 entre la
cantidad de tiempo que se tarda jorge
pero jorge se tarda dos veces la
cantidad de tiempo que se tarda lanza
entonces aquí lo que tenemos es 1 entre
2 a y ahora sí tenemos una ecuación con
una sola variable desconocida entonces
podemos determinar exactamente cuánto
vale esta variable desconocida y bueno
la forma más fácil de resolver esta
ecuación es multiplicar de los dos lados
de la ecuación
por 8 por a de 8 x
y como seguramente puedes ver se van a
cancelar un montón de cosas entonces
haciendo estas cuentas tenemos aquí 8 x
entre 8 esto es simplemente una a y eso
es igual a 1 entre a por 8 y eso es 8 es
un simple 8 porque las a se van a
cancelar a entre la desigualdad uno más
uno entre dos a por ocho y eso es 8
entre 2 que es igual a 4 a es igual a 84
que si vale 12 la danza se tarda 12
horas en pintar la verdad ahora qué es
lo que nos estaban preguntando
no se están preguntando cuánto tiempo se
tardaron aransay jorge cuando estaban
pintando solos que ya sabemos cuánto se
tardó aranza pero nos falta averiguar
cuánto se tardó jorge ahora la respuesta
está por aquí que nosotros sabemos que
por qué se tardó el doble de lo que se
tardó balanza
entonces nosotros sabemos que jorge se
tardó dos veces la cantidad de tiempo
que se tardó balance o sea que se tardó
2 x 12 horas que es igual a 24
horas y listo ya terminamos aransay
jorge cuando estaban trabajando juntos
se tardaron ocho horas en pintar la
barda lo cual tiene todo el sentido del
mundo porque pues sí aranza se tarda 12
horas en pintarla pero cuando está
trabajando solita si trabaja con jorge
pues uno podría pensar que puede
trabajar el doble de rápido y entonces
se deberían de tardar seis horas en
terminar de pintar la verdad pero pues
jorge no es tan eficiente como arantxa
entonces tiene sentido que se tarden un
poco más bueno nos vemos en el próximo
vídeo